this guy thought he would be kissing  Katy Perry  instead he seemingly got catfished I've  been talking to this woman  okay the last six years I've been love  with her it's Katy to say wow that's a  sneak peek of MTV's new episode of  catfish Spencer seems to think he's been  in a relationship with singer Katy Perry  he's just never met her no Skype calls  yeah no phone calls no we're also  wondering how this guy thought he was  dating KP when over the last six years  she has publicly dated John Mayer even  been married to Russell Brand and of  course now she's seeing Orlando Bloom  maybe he thought they were in an open  relationship  catfish shares Wednesday night on MTV